I'll rather you just keep massaging
money instead of Tuscany ever and
pulling my hair no Mikey race I'm Phil
I'm mark mark all right I will enjoy
taking the hairs off of your legs
I hope Zdenek Denning I hope dennings
kind to me the nerves are slowly
building well I haven't had my legs
waxed before and I never really planned
to but we're about to change that don't
we take out a double wax strip and rub
it in between your hands dude this is
not coming off easy at all
very romantic mmm and now you rub my leg
rad yeah ain't no sister what the
instructions clearly state be brave
the faster you pull B brown hair you'll
remove so you ready you're brave ah okay
ready one two ah [ __ ] Oh Oh oooh that's
sounded like it hurt you need to go up
that's along the grain of the hair oh I
was going up with you that's probably
why I said oh you know that hurts
significantly more than the first time
that was really painful what is this
that's like landing straight as a
landing scoop started Brazilian people
pay extra for that [ __ ] there's no way
girls do that they do laser now they
don't do Axanar that's why you not just
shave your legs and you name a laser
that here you can frame this and it
could be like a piece of Modern Art
waxing the strangers legs it's probably
a lot easier than waxing someone you
know because you don't have that trust
that can be lost it wasn't as bad as I
thought yeah yeah I have an appreciation
I guess yeah I'm feeling very different
that's smooth I must say that my leg is
still falling his bed button so I'm
gonna have to wear jeans for the next
few months like as far as whether or not
I like this look I think I might I might
keep it around to see how it works you
know I'll still test it out experiment
with it never doing this again
now it's done done